inflation
is our friend
for example consider this
in the year 2000 if current trends
continue the average blue-collar annual
wage in this country will be 568
thousand dollars
think what this inflated world of the
future will mean
most americans will be millionaires
everyone will feel like a big shot
wouldn't you like to own a 4 000 suit
and smoke a 75 cigar
drive a 600 000 car
i know i would
but what about people on fixed incomes
they have always been the true victims
of inflation that's why i will present
to congress the inflation maintenance
program whereby the u.s treasury will
make up any inflation cost losses
through direct tax rebates to the public
in cash
now you may say won't that cost a lot of
money won't that increase the deficit
sure it will
but so what we'll just print more money
we have the papers we have the mints
i can just call up the bureau of
engraving and say hi
this is gemma
roll off some of them 20s
print up a couple of thousand sheets of
those century notes
sure the glot of dollars will cause even
more inflation but who cares
everybody will be a millionaire
how you doing people happy monday i'm
dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message on april 4th 2022 we're
live streaming on rumble blaze tv and
youtube subscribe all that good stuff
and yes that was a clip
from 1978
about 43 years ago
saturday night live when it was funny a
long long time ago you young kids
watching this program won't remember
that saturday live once was funny and
relevant and irreverent but it was and
of course that was dan aykroyd playing
jimmy carter and basically what was edgy
comedy
in 1978
is the truth of 2022. you see what they
did there everything that he said there
is exactly what the policies of the
biden administration are it's rather
extraordinary and i saw it over the
weekend and i was like that has got
has got to be the cold open and in some
ways the theme of today's show before we
get to it and we've got a big show for
you today a jam-packed show uh i wanted
to show you some pictures here because
on thursday
i was at the prageru gala i was the host
of the prager ugala and you may
recognize the back of those two heads
there sitting in the front row as i was
giving my talk right up top yes on the
left that is florida governor ron
desantis and having a fork full of
something is dennis prager of prager
university uh after dennis and uh the
governor did their talk there's me
shaking the governor's hand and then i
wanted to show you this uh side by side
here i actually gave the governor the
first signed copy of don't burn this
country and on the right that's when i
said gay to him so you see his reaction
and you're not going to believe this
guys i was not arrested he actually took
a picture with me and david i said this
is my husband david he took a picture
with us he said oh congratulations on
the kids very happy for you guys
took a picture we'll try to get the
picture it was the official photographer
there and just everything that they say
about the guy is a lie and he gave a
great talk and florida's in good shape
and you know all that stuff uh one other
thing before we get to uh to the program
uh we did finally i was able to confirm
uh the opener for my event
the book tour event in denver we had
been holding this one for a while uh
comedian and my buddy brian callan
will be opening for me in denver so you
can go to daverubin.com
events and we've got all sorts of people
at all sorts of shows real quick as you
know don jr opening for me in west palm
bennie johnson in clearwater florida
andrew clavin and raleigh michael males
in atlanta youngby park in chicago glenn
back in dallas megan mccain in dc megan
kelly in west niagara new york
prager that prager guy over in brea
california larry elder in oxnard douglas
murray we just added that one as well in
san jose blake masters next senator from
arizona in phoenix brian callan in
denver we have one or two more that
we're going to be adding and all the
tickets uh come with a copy of the book
and we just opened up a lot of the vips
had sold out we just opened up i think
20 more tickets at each one if you want
to do that one second hug with me okay
enough promo let's get to the show so
the big thing today this just broke this
morning
and it's kind of fitting because my dm
on friday the q a dm that we did on
friday the one story that i covered up
top was that there has been a rumor over
the last week or so that elon musk might
start his own social media platform and
then there were some rumors even
furthering on that that he might buy
twitter or buy a stake in twitter and
you know when all of these things happen
it's a little hard to gauge you know
what's real and you know are people just
teasing out things and you know is he
really going to do something or is this
just to keep his name in the news all of
that stuff but elon musk is not just a
talker he's actually a doer and as of
this morning
uh elon musk the owner and and ceo and
founder of tesla and spacex and the
boring company whole bunch of other
stuff well he uh now ladies and
gentlemen is the largest owner in
twitter at
9.2 percent we've got some info here
from bloomberg elon musk has taken a 9.2
stake in twitter incorporated to become
the platform's biggest shareholder a
week after he hinted he might shake up
the social media industry twitter shares
surged about 26 in pre-market trading
after musk's purchase was revealed
monday in a regulatory filing the stake
is worth about 2.89
billion based on friday's market close
musk 50 years old polled his more than
80 million followers on twitter last
month asking them whether the company
adheres to the principles of free speech
after more than 70 percent said no he
asked whether a new platform was needed
and said he was giving serious thought
to starting his own the announcement
will be yet another major test for new
twitter ceo prague agrawal who replaced
jack dorsey after he unexpectedly
resigned in november agrawal vowed to
increase accountability make decisions
faster and to improve product execution
the company set ambitious goals for
growth including increasing annual
revenue to 7.5 billion and getting to
315 million daily users by the end of
2023 musk posted a cryptic meme in
december after twitter announced that
agrawal was taking over from dorsey's
twitter ceo it depicted agrawal as
soviet dictator joseph stalin and dorsey
as soviet secret police head nikolai
yazov for being shoved into water
now what's super interesting about this
is not just that elon musk just put his
money where his mouth is 2.89 billion
that's a lot of cash even when you got
his kind of money uh but now he is the
the largest stakeholder in twitter and
then something else very interesting
happened over the weekend and i suspect
a lot of mainstream media outlets are
going to skip over this one jack dorsey
the former
ceo of twitter the guy who looks like
he's on a perpetual mushroom trip uh he
tweeted this out and this is before the
announcement that elon musk had bought
these shares he wrote the days of usenet
irc that's internet relay chat the web
even email with pgp were amazing
centralizing discovery and identity into
corporations really damage the internet
i realize that i'm partially to blame
and regret it
now i don't want to sound like a
conspiracy theorist here but i don't
think these things are disconnected i
think he obviously knew
somehow over the weekend that elon musk
was about to do this right people talk
lawyers talk etc etc and he now realizes
if elon musk now is the majority has the
majority uh of the shares not the
majority 51 but he is the highest
personal stake in twitter
it is very possible that some of the
books are going to be opened up at
twitter
have you guys been shadow banning have
you been reading people's dms who was it
that said we're not going to allow the
new york post to tweet out the links to
the hunter biden story and we're going
to
censor other people's links when they
try to link to it as well how have you
decided to suspend certain people and to
ban certain people in the summer of 2021
when that crazy right-wing maniac dave
rubin said that vaccine mandates were
coming who was it that decided to
suspend him turned out he was right uh i
think jack could end up being in a lot
of trouble and he was just trying to get
ahead of it there he was trying to get
some sympathy like oh there was a cool
internet and i really bungled it uh but
please have mercy on me because i'm not
in charge anymore so we will see what
happens here is elon musk's goal to
really clean up what's going on on
twitter is he going to let donald trump
back on twitter uh is he going to expose
the nonsense that's been going on there
we will see but this
is a good move right what do i always
tell you guys we got to find that star
in the distance we got to find
the thing and the people that are
fighting the right way well here's a guy
putting his butt on the line not only
his butt he's putting his his money on
the line and saying
we're gonna we're gonna see if we can
fix this thing so this is this is really
good of course the funny part about this
is that it just shows you how far the
left and the woke machine has gone with
everything that a guy like elon musk who
probably had i kid you not he probably
had a hundred meetings where people said
to him do you want to get in on twitter
or in on social media over the last
couple years probably more than 100
meetings like try to imagine the amount
of times that something's been pitched
to this guy related to social media that
these people have gone so crazy with the
censorship that the nonsense related to
uh gender identity the fact that tucker
carlson the largest highest rated cable
news talk show host in history is
currently banned from twitter still
right now nobody's talking about it but
it's true they finally pushed a guy like
elon musk who will be considered a
right-wing maniac because of this uh to
get involved and get his skin in the
game and i think actually that's a
beautiful thing
and we need it more than ever and that
really is the theme of today's show
because the people that are in charge
biden gay pete racist pelosi crazy
kamala and jen sake who's now taking a
job at msnbc a little conflict of
interest there these people are wrong
about everything and have been wrong
about everything the entire freaking
time
that's what we're doing today and if any
of the things that they've been wrong
about
make you nauseous well i've got the
relief for you people uh relief band you
know one out of three americans
regularly suffer from nausea or anxiety
usually while watching cnn and if you're
one of them you know how quickly your
body can turn from comfort to crisis
mode and this is why you've got to check
out relief band relief band is the
number one fda cleared anti-nausea
wristband that has been clinically
proven to relieve and prevent nausea and
vomiting associated with motion sickness
anxiety migraines hangovers morning
sickness chemotherapy and so much more
relief band is a band you wear on your
wrist that stimulates a nerve in the
wrist that travels to the parts of the
brain that control nausea blocking the
signal to your brain
which is sending to your stomach telling
you that you're sick you simply change
the intensity depending on how you're
feeling to make it stronger or weaker
the technology was originally developed
in hospitals to relieve patients but now
through relief bands it's available to
the masses the products 100 drug-free
non-drowsy and provides all-natural
long-lasting relief with zero side
effects for as long as needed their
newest model relief band sport is
waterproof has extended battery life and
can attach to your apple or android
watch relief man makes a great gift any
time of year right now they've got an
exclusive offer just for the reuben
report audience if you go to
reliefband.com and use promo code ruben
you'll receive 20 off plus free shipping
and no questions asked for 30 day money
back guarantee that's the best offer
you'll find for relief man anywhere but
you have to use my code head on over to
r e l i e f b a n d dot com and use my
promo code ruben for 20 off plus free
shipping and now back to me
all right so you know we've got some
problems in this country you know we've
got a president who
doesn't seem like he's all there
we have people who don't believe in math
we have other people who believe you can
endlessly print money we have people who
believe the borders should be open we
have people who believe that boys are
girls and girls are boys we have people
who believe that non-racism is racism
and we also have people who just flat
out don't understand anything about
anything that would be the generous
version and the more cynical version
would be that they want to destroy the
whole damn thing here's nancy pelosi
but
we cannot allow the fossil fuel industry
to use this as an excuse to reverse
everything we're doing to save the
planet
one of the things i think that the
president may say i don't have this as a
fact is that we will use the
defense production act to
speed up a
diversification
uh so that we're not so dependent
on oil
okay if you believe that that alcoholic
geriatric buffoon is up to the task of
saving the planet then i'd like to sell
you a bridge um you can really see
what's going on here we now have this
crisis this war
in ukraine
no excuses for what russia has done you
cannot invade a sovereign nation and
just start killing innocent people
but because of this over the last say
month and a half or so and it really
started a little bit before because we
had a slow motion entry into the war
remember for weeks biden kept saying
well i think putin's going to do it and
i gave him a list of things he can't do
and maybe he's going to do this or that
and you know in two days i'm pretty sure
it's going to happen through
you can see what this is really about
and what this really seemingly about is
about at this point is crashing the
american economy and ushering in this
green new deal and getting us off gas
and oil and fossil fuels and all those
things which coincidentally is exactly
what these people have wanted to do the
entire time so
look even if
even if you hate fossil fuels and if you
really hate fossil fuels there's a lot
of things in your life you shouldn't be
doing okay and petroleums and pretty
much everything in your house and your
clothes and all of that stuff but even
if you absolutely hate fossil fuels and
even if you absolutely believe greta
thunder when it comes to climate change
and all of those things the idea that
these people are competent enough to
actually transition us off properly from
the the fuel literally the fuel that has
been fueling the economy and our culture
and our civilization for a hundred plus
years really more than that
to their green new deal
to their idea of all renewable energy
and that is what will keep us safe and
everything else that they're competent
enough to do that is really really crazy
but they're now telling you that that
really is what this is all about what
does a government do a government never
lets a good crisis go to waste and
they're going oh we've got a war over
there so we are going to figure out how
to usher in all the nonsense that we
want to do here but we've got gay pete
and i always i only call him gay pete
because the only reason he has the job
as transportation secretary is because
he's gay that's not just something i'm
saying that's what biden said you know
we've got the first openly gay
transportation secretary we've got the
first openly trans health secretary
deputy something something uh having
nothing to do with his qualifications
because obviously he's not qualified he
was the mayor of south bend indiana
that's pretty much all he's ever done
and that's a perfectly fine job i
suppose but he knows nothing about
transportation but he's ushering in an
era of equity and all sorts of stuff and
he really wants you to get rid of your
car our country was better positioned to
handle it than many others so less
dependent on foreign oil and that
protects us from shortages at fuel
stations but here's the thing to
remember even if all of the oil we use
in the usa were made in the usa the
price of it is still subject to powers
and dynamics outside of the usa which
means that until we achieve a form of
energy independence that is based on
clean energy created here at home
american citizens will still be
vulnerable to wild price hikes
no lie lie complete lie pete what are
you talking about even if all of our
energy was made here at home so all of
our oil and energy was made on we'd
still be subject to wild price hacks
no we wouldn't because we have plenty of
energy here we just have not unleashed
it properly
and it wouldn't be if we were energy
independent right something that there
was that orange guy always forget his
name that he wanted to do
then we wouldn't be so dependent so that
if russia invades ukraine we wouldn't
see these crazy spikes so that's a
complete lie but then even furthers the
lie and this is what they do with
everything they lie about everything and
then they lie about that his next
statement is in essence we just have to
get to clean energy and if we can just
have clean energy then we won't be
reliant on these spikes but what are you
talking about if if we have full
oil energy energy independence
regardless of whether it's fossil fuels
or whether it's clean energy
what's the difference if we can do it
all ourselves then why would clean
energy not have anything to do
with the spikes right they just
lie about everything but again this is
the plan so you've got pelosi saying you
better let us do what we want to do
because we got to save the planet then
you have pete just flat out lying just
lying about energy independence and
really then at the end telling you what
he wants to do it's not about energy
independence it's about moving us all to
electric okay and by the way uh the joe
biden fella man pretending to be uh
president he's very excited because he
might be able to save you eighty dollars
a month
under my plan
which is before the congress now we can
take advantage of the next generation of
electric vehicles
that a typical driver will save about
eighty dollars a month
from not having to pay gas at the pump
congrats everybody
you're going to save 80 a month of
course you're gonna have to buy an
electric car and even with whatever
subsidies the government might give you
might is the key part there uh electric
cars still cost way more uh joe i don't
know if you know this but a lot of
people are hurting economically right
now okay so
you know they're not looking to get
electric cars you know if you can get
say a regular sedan you know you get a
very sort of basic simple sedan for i
don't know 14 000 bucks you can though
they exist right um you know you have to
spend at least at least 50 000 on an
electric vehicle so
what are we talking about here joe are
you saying that these people have to
take out huge loans forever i thought
you guys don't like loans either because
you don't like interest or math doesn't
work or something so what actually are
you saying that you can save 80 of
course this is the same guy who tweeted
out on july 4th that the average
american was going to save 16 cents on
their july 4th picnic so uh yeah i think
you get i think you get the point uh but
it continues because then there's jen
sake you know i love jen sake
she was doing her white house press
briefing and one thing you know you have
to keep in mind as you watch the videos
of john saki look how miserable she
looks but you really got to see the
misery in her face because i think that
over time if you lie and lie and lie and
then if you lie about that that
eventually it will start making it so
that your face will actually be sliding
off your skull gen sucking so how are
people supposed to believe
the putin price hike is to blame for
food prices going up when the timeline
doesn't add up
well here's what the president is
reflecting on one the the price of gas
has gone up by approximately a dollar or
more uh since uh putin started lining up
troops at the border this is something
that outside economists have spoken to
as well not just the administration and
those are just factual details about how
much the price of gas has gone up we
know that's a huge impact uh and when
you say inflation people think the cost
on their pocketbook and the impact on
their budgets the second piece on the
availability of food we know that
different markets around the world are
impacted
by
by the lack of production in ukraine and
other because of the war and we know
that that could impact global food
prices
this is the first time we've heard the
president blame putin for higher food
prices i think what the president's
looking at is what the impact has been
in a lot of areas that are leading to
price increases on people's pocketbooks
and where we could see it increasing
over the course of time
okay so let's do the second part first
the food stuff now remember before when
i said that there was this like slow
motion lead to the war and you all
remember that hopefully when biden just
for weeks kept saying you know okay he's
going to go in or we think he's going to
go in and he's about to go in how come
nobody in mainstream media none of our
political elite or any of our
trustworthy sources were warning us that
if we did anything related to ukraine
that food was going to go up because you
think maybe uh we would have had a
discussion about that because i don't
think the average person likes when they
go to the store and they see the prices
of food exploding which we all know is
happening right now you do not need me
to tell you that just go to your store
whatever your stories go and does stuff
seem more expensive and are there less
things on the shelves pretty much
everywhere the answer is yes so she's
just this idea that they didn't know
that food was gonna rise or what was
gonna happen if we did anything in
ukraine okay that's just nonsense and
then of course she lies through a
mission on the first part related to gas
because she says that you know since the
war price of gas has gone up by about a
dollar and that actually is true
what she forgets to tell you and we've
covered this a bajillion times the price
of gas when joe biden became president
in january of 2021 was two dollars and
42 cents the average price of gas
in february of 2022 so a year later but
before ukraine
it was up three dollars and 61 cents now
i'm not a mathemagician but that seems
like about a dollar twenty to me before
the war so gas was raising faster before
the war than since the war she doesn't
say that of course because now you know
anything that happens here guys if
prices go up and you can't get food and
the supply chain's bad and some other
stuff's going on it's not cause of them
it's that there's this guy putin this
putin guy he's doing some stuff
he's doing stuff uh but saki continued
to get pressed uh because this is just
so perfect
when you wanna know what the swamp is
like what is the swamp really when
people talk about the swamp
and and this giant circle jerk that is
our political machine and our media
machine well it was announced over the
weekend that jen saki will be leaving
her job as white house press secretary
and where is she going to go
no not to a lobbying firm but that would
have been a good guess she's going to
msnbc does that seem ethical well she
was asked
is it ethical for you to continue
conducting this job
while negotiating
with the media
well
i have always gone over and above the
stringent ethical and legal requirements
of the biden administration and i take
that very seriously and
as a standard for every employee of the
white house i have received rigorous
ethics counseling including
as it relates to any future employment
i've complied with all ethics
requirements and gone beyond and taken
steps to recuse myself from
decisions as appropriate
guys guys if ethics are here this girl
freaking
like she's like a male in a female
competition pole vaulting she's just
just leaves everybody behind because
this is mrs ethics
okay this is complete nonsense this
woman all she has done for the last year
of her life is lie about absolutely
everything they're there i don't think
there's anyone in america that has lied
more
she is the per capita winner for the
lying award okay
and what is she going to do what is her
reward
for that award her reward is to get a
job at msnbc so now msnbc is most likely
going to pay her a seven figure salary
she will probably make over a million
dollars a year that's a lot of cash to
just continue to lie on msnbc msnbc is a
propaganda network she just worked for a
propaganda president to now work in a
propaganda network as an analyst by the
way i'm sure that's what she's going to
be as an analyst they will i don't know
that they're giving her her own show
right off the top although that would be
propaganda in and of itself but they
will bring her on to analyze the news
and do you think that a woman
who uh just spent the last year lying
for administration and administration
and has all sorts of connections and
friends in that building the white house
and in the capital of those things do
you think she can honestly assess and
comment on what's going on there and by
the way this is not just about her this
is what they all do this is what they
all do george stephanopoulos the now
chief head of what is it abc news uh he
was in the bill clinton white house this
is they all go through all of these
things you're head of the dnc next thing
you know you're a cnn analyst you're a
failed political campaigner campaigner
next thing you know you're on msnbc news
the game that they are constantly
uh forcing us to play
we can see it we all see the rules now
and that's why so many people are
checking out that's why so many people
are watching this or watching the you
know the daily wire watching glenn beck
or watching whatever else people are
watching whatever the complete other
side of us are you the lefty lunatic
version of me somebody's watching that
and i don't blame them because they even
realize how stupid mainstream media has
become uh and you know saki she's gonna
bring you know her incredible insight
and her um
word trickery to msnbc here's what she
had to say about pregnant people what
beginning today as many as 720 000
pregnant and postpartum people across
the united states could be guaranteed
medicaid and children's health insurance
program coverage for up for a full 12
months after pregnancy thanks to the
american rescue plan
pregnant people pregnant people
these used to be known as women women
are the only gender that can get
pregnant
i don't want to sound like a racist or a
nazi it's a monday morning i'm feeling
good about life but that is the truth
women can get pregnant women have wombs
eggs the whole shebang okay there's no
such thing as a pregnant person yes a
woman is a pregnant person i suppose if
we're being very technical but you see
what they do with everything they lie
and obfuscate and confuse language and
don't say gay even though you can say
gay as i made a point on on ben
shapiro's podcast this morning but don't
say gave a little sidebar they could
have just as easily called it don't say
straight because you're just not allowed
to talk about sex with a kid from k
through 3. so it's all nonsense black
lives matter is that really what this
thing's about the lgbtqi plus blah blah
blah
tanks all of this nonsense pregnant
people we're in 1984 and she's been one
of the my voice just cracked i think i
just
i finally hit puberty um
yeah you see what's going on here people
i think you do see what's going on here
but don't worry
don't worry saki's heading out of the
administration but there are good people
there are good people at the
administration there are smart people
that she can leave this up to
um like kamala harris right she's she is
this woman i mean you talk about people
that are on the ball that know what
they're doing
you look at her like you if you if you
were putting in the dictionary like
smart they're going to show you a
picture of kamalas here she is back in
july of 2021 uh because if you think the
woke-ism thing isn't going to stop
they've been ushering in this for a long
long time and and when you figure it out
you realize that they're the racists
they're the ones that hate middle
america and everything else
they look down on all of us and here's
kamala you may remember this one from uh
about eight months ago uh talking about
people in middle america is agreeing to
voter id one of those compromises that
you'd support i don't think that we
should
underestimate what
that could mean
because in some people's mind that means
well you're going to have to
um
xerox or
photocopy your id to send it in to prove
you are who you are well there are a
whole lot of people especially people
who live in rural communities who don't
there's no kinkos there's no office max
near them
people have to understand that when
we're talking about voter id laws
be clear about who you have in mind and
what would be required of them to prove
who they are
of course people have to prove who they
are
but not in a way that makes it them it
almost impossible for them to prove who
they are
it's just so extraordinary like you just
have to laugh the stupidity first off
when she says of course people have to
prove who they are did she just come out
as for identification because that's
racist according to her own party um
also this idea that people in the middle
of the country they can't get to a
kinkos what are these
effin morons there's no kinkos or office
macs near them they don't have printers
they don't have a 99 hewlett packard
printer that has a thing and you can
lift it and put your id on it and scan
it these people are complete warrants
what's hilarious about this is these are
the same people
who think that black people are too
stupid to be able to get an id so they
hate middle american people because they
can't get to a kinkos or don't know how
to use a printer and they also think
that black people who live in the inner
city are too stupid to figure out how to
get an id they hate all of us they
really do hate all of us you know we'll
do this will be a fun little thing to do
if uh if you're living in middle america
and you've got a printer
could you take a picture of your printer
tweet it at me and i'll retweet some
printers or other devices that you might
do you have a photocopy machine an old
school xerox that people used to sit on
to xerox their butt do you have one of
those send me some pictures very
exciting and i'd like to and maybe i'll
tag kamala because she needs to know
that they're out there
but the point is that uh if saki leaves
well you've got kamala she's pretty good
i think i made that point and we've also
got this pelosi lady and she's sticking
around uh here's a gem from her a couple
days ago
do you agree with members of your caucus
who are saying that clarence thomas
should resign
i don't think he should have ever been
appointed so let me take it back
oh you don't think that clarence thomas
ever should have been appointed isn't
that what we call racist these days
right anyone that didn't want katanji
brown jackson
uh to be appointed to be confirmed for
the supreme court weren't they
racist
uh but uh just because
you know you're a lefty you get to say
whatever you want and nobody calls you
racist well i call you racist you're a
waiter you're a racist wench you're a
racist wench nancy pelosi that's what
you are you really really are uh but
there's this other guy so let's say
you're looking at this thing and you're
going man saki's leaving but we'll be
okay because we got the uh we got the
kamala
and we got the uh the pelosi uh well
we've also got biden right at the end of
the day the buck stops with biden and uh
he's a pretty bright fella
we have this notion that somehow if
you're poor you cannot do it poor kids
are just as bright and just as talented
white kids
poor kids just as talented as white kids
extraordinary extraordinary but now
allow me to show you something
completely different because the
democrats had a chance they really did
have a chance in that last election
because there was one
sane human being
on that uh that podium when they were
having their debates and they destroyed
her not only did they destroy her
you know who i'm talking about already
tulsi gabbard obviously but hillary
clinton claimed that she was working for
the russians mitt romney in the last
month or so claim that she's working for
the russians and she's a traitor this is
tulsi gabbard who was congresswoman from
hawaii democrat congresswoman from
hawaii who was an active member of our
military which has been in training over
the last couple weeks
they they completely destroyed her
i don't know where someone that is
roughly sane fits in the modern
democratic party but tulsi who's now out
of politics and i don't know exactly
what her future holds i don't know if
she wants to get into politics
or not uh she's still talking the truth
and she's still holding the same line
which is very difficult as someone
that
i think still believes that they're on
the left again i don't want to speak for
tulsi uh here's a video she put up on
instagram over the weekend talking about
hb1557
otherwise known as the don't say gay or
straight bill
you may have seen in the news recently
or you may be a parent who's experienced
how parental rights are under attack all
across the country as the government
tries to usurp parents rights and
responsibility to raise their own
children
now we should all support the parental
rights and education bill that recently
passed in florida which very simply bans
government and government schools from
indoctrinating woke sexual values in our
schools
to a captive audience a captive audience
that is by law required to attend
but as i read the legislation i got to
tell you i was shocked to learn that it
only protects kids from kindergarten
till third grade
third grade what about 12th grade
or not at all
now government
has no place in our personal lives
government has no place in our bedrooms
parents are the ones responsible for
raising their kids and instilling in
them a moral foundation
not the government
who seems more sane
is it gen sake
is it nancy pelosi
is it joe biden
is it kamala harris
or is it the lady that the entire party
and the entire machine tried to destroy
what's extraordinary about that video
actually well first off she's calm and
clear and decent like you can feel it
right you can always feel it with her
but what's really extraordinary about
that video is that what she's saying is
in essence desantis didn't go far enough
that it shouldn't just be k through
three that
up until 12th grade
you should not be teaching this stuff in
schools that's a really interesting
position to have now we can have some
discussion i think of what a health
class should teach
related to
the body and puberty and all of the
things that kids are going through and i
had health class in seventh grade but
they weren't pushing gender identity
stuff on us they weren't telling you
that you should
transition from one gender to another
and then try to hide that from the
parents so tulsi just i mean i believe
that was an intentional line and that's
a pretty powerful line that she's saying
he did not even go far enough
so what's the theme now that we've come
to the almost the ending of today's show
although i want you to stick around for
the uh the cold clothes today it's a
good one
um what what's the theme here well if
you start with elon musk you got a guy
who most people think of as really just
a technologist an innovator
not particularly political somewhat
libertarian in some ways but then you
know enjoys his government subsidies but
he will now be thought of as a right
winger sort of because he's trying to
clean up things related to speech and we
know that it's the conservative side or
the right that's having their speech
stifled okay
then we jump all the way to tulsi and
you have a democrat congresswoman former
congresswoman who is now
in some ways related to this hb1557
sounding more right-wing that's not
really the case but more let's say
conservative
than even ron desantis who's being
called a nazi and everything else by
mainstream media this all shows you how
insane the left has gone and and
even bigger than that i think what it
shows you is what i'm actually really
interested in right now which is what
will this alliance look like how will we
have an alliance of technologists like
elon musk how will we have an alliance
of say
more traditionally religious people say
like my evangelical christian friends
and an orthodox jew like ben shapiro how
do we couple that with someone a refugee
i know a little bit about the refugees
from the left a refugee of the left like
tulsi gabbard all of us having wildly
different personal religious beliefs
philosophies all of those things
but all going man
america is pretty good
individual rights are pretty good
we want to build new things while they
burn everything down
that's a great story that's what i'm
interested in uh that's how i ended the
show on friday that that that piece of
now okay we've seen it we've seen the
thing the curtains back we've seen it
you guys aren't gonna stop i get it
department of education is never going
to stop california is never going to
stop
what do we have to do to disconnect from
these people and how can we find all of
the people that can fit into our wide
tent which is exactly what america is
all about that's what i'm interested in
i think that's what you're interested in
and that's what i'm going to keep
furthering guys uh it is meme monday
over at
reubenreport.locals.com here's the meme
that i put up this morning finally the
fourth ape he is the sum of the first
three he sees nobody hears nobody that
speaks to nobody because he's staring at
twitter all day long we got hundreds of
people putting in their funny memes of
the day so if you want to join us
rubenreport.locals.com couple comments
from the locals community before the
call closed drake says an amount of
groceries that usually costs me around
65 bucks now cost a hundred yeah i get
it i see it you know i think we're
seeing a little less of a version of it
here in florida because of low taxes and
everything else and because the state is
just functioning and people aren't being
left you know uh jobs aren't being just
decimated the way they were in
california and everything else but even
here we're seeing prices go up and i've
mentioned many times you know we're
trying to do some construction at the
house and i want to rebuild the studio
and a few other things and it's
literally to get a window it's like six
months
so these are problems that are real
problems and they are not problems
because of vladimir putin there are
problems because of our administration
they are problems because of all the
things that dan aykroyd was saying at
the beginning of the show that you
cannot just print money and think it
does not have any consequences logan
says the stringent ethical legal
requirements of the biden administration
haha good one yeah that is hilarious
like yes the biden administration has
stringent ethical
standards uh well
you're gonna have to look into that
laptop thing if so because there's
emails on there that implicate joe
related to hunter getting jobs for
things that he didn't have any expertise
in and getting a lot of cash that was
most likely funneled up to the big guy
not gonna hear that on cnn tonight uh
jeff finally says it's not racist if it
is for
the facts yes we all know that right all
the people who told us that having a id
card to vote was racist were the exact
same people who said that you had to
have vaccine passports to go to
mcdonald's
the disconnect the mental disconnect
that jump whatever happened the synapse
that's not there
it's extraordinary people
uh all right guys reminder uh don't burn
this country is coming out in less than
two weeks not this tuesday but the
tuesday after
uh daverubin.com book you can get your
book it will be delivered to you on the
12th and we've got the links for all the
different websites that you can go to to
purchase the book and i am heading out
on tour davereuben.com events and the
big one that we announced uh just this
morning is that brian callan comedian
brian cowan my buddy and great comic
this is going to be a fun show and i
think denver's almost sold out already
uh he will be joining me in denver and
we also just added uh douglas mario will
be opening for me in san jose you can go
to davereuben.com
events for the tickets my interview with
jordan belfort the wolf of wall street
the full thing is up at the blaze and on
rumble and on youtube and it's our new
and improved quasi
home studio it's in my house we shot it
downstairs i think it looks pretty
freaking sharp we're going to build out
some more stuff and locals is opening a
studio here in miami
so we can do more in-person things
rather than do it right here in this
studio but i think you will dig it
and finally i promised you a cold close
and i'm a man of my word unlike everyone
involved in this sham of the
administration have a good day everybody
and i'm deeply proud of the work she's
doing as first lady with joining forces
initiative she started with michelle
obama when she was vice president and
now cars on